але гвинт за те, що твоя держава не була в
твоїх кордонах якісь [ __ ] чиновники
Ян Зрозуміло зашкварки бувають регулярно
постійно оборони все абсолютно
коруптивна історія І тут я покажу
добавкою ходи
річки мільйони на музей голодомору
ідіотськи допомогла
ніби я сказав
так мої попередні
сьогодні стрілкою культурним продюсером
за рік оголошення білоцерк просила
моно церкви протестантська церква сіль
чоч називається багатіїв запорошував з
України ж закину
Прийшовши була Тіна Кароль сказала б у цій
фурор Усі заходи богочення забирають на
свої потреби в даному
еквалантера вона була задача
підрозділі століттями опікуюся і
сверднути з херсону імен ми розбирали
на що він там трохи Бірюса кістки причому
тисячі доларів забрав владу Я продав
прапор завдяки
його автографом так називається про
поролонкомандувача там ще там не
напасти такий світ нам потрібен був учора
сьогодні безпосередньо за 6200 доларів я
люблю що ціни результат
під поїздку в Сакраменто дякую навушники
покажу церкві сіль Джордж у хача артиста
наші душі часто і продуктивно виступають
за кордоном у США Я часто аудиторії
бомбоксу без обмажем Скай антотил
українці Він про таку наших корів
українських річки виїхав і зараз тому
що мене за Кордон хочеш
звивистими синицями це йому треба допомагати
українцям я кіт ви стала з роду з
України
я скажу так
не совісті
Я сказав один вишко і добровільно
обираючий ще знає люди і того
вони поросли земне він багатих безтурботний
для мене кришкова ніштяк то виїхав годинник
бути в будинок сказати ще я їх заслуговую
більше нікого не подав до рук і там не
буде з ними розбавлятися напевно можна
все сказати це можеш
інтерв'ю ви зайшов шкірного свого села
українці допомагають
свої Правда ці ситуації
[музика]
Я кістку реабили ту Ватса в українську
культурі ніж доїдь 7 заріс Я готовий
думаю що Росія точно не вдається
стовідсотково черга сил мій будньому
закласти вигляд їх невидимкою їх
стратегії вибочення так
б ясними Чому так було Ну і так далі
той хто народ натиснули не натиснути правильно
сказав народ може бути що Будько е
особливу українську Дивний політичному
народ той факт, що воно було Е після
чотирнадцятого уроку після хвороби уроку
продовжив у Росії е для мани
Показники того що вони ну він не
переживає
в тому числі
набрала виступаючий у Росії перед
загадником перед буттям ту мету та шлях
не знаю знайшли ти повірите знав що таке
Я ж не сказав, що я про них забув
бородатий кішки неоку з ваших
Світлана
призначаєш я своїм статутом
свою точку зорори зробилося
окупації Криму та розрізання на сході
України
і шоу-бізнесі такі протити видають чек
на протококсану Марченку Віктором
[оплески]
[музика]
будемо слідкуваті ми знаємо Чому вона не
прийшла
там народ якось народ не знаю як і
народ Криму та донбасу не знаю таких
народів він не може матері свою точку
зору Я сказав що по-моєму не
все дружити мисками і ми процівали
тому що у мене був контракту мамі був
контракт
розвернуся залишили прийшов і Взяли б
кого з Москви вам було б далі
кому я
в українському політику та українську
культурній сфері таких Пані Оксана
Марченко
раніше і тут в Україні проводити свою
діяльність
абсолютно коруптивна історія і тут
добавки
зараз Зеленський
[музика]
бойового духу найбільший подій Коли
позіхаються на все вбрання Я хочу
заявляється новий партії відро наві
хаймерса і ракети дуникколи ппо там все
дадуть пару нам усіх нібито називається
Патріотів
обіцяє м'ясо
тому що люди зрозуміло їх не брати
Я думаю що він там у шоці ну я не думаю
я знаю
знайти фільми те які культурний продукт
моя місія буде
історія як документалка документальні
фільми їх які ви займаєтеся зарістю
тому що документальні
українських оборонних та
документально буде зафіксовано
російського фашизму
ми будемо сексуатом і Путін ціни ми можемо
Руїни знати Руїни ціни на те, що вже
нижчою так би ми це Аспект
документалістів
я все на сто відсотків
на шосе Ну так очевидно буде контур
пропаганди прямого на як розвінчу
фейки російські до даємо житлові звістки
розібратися в масі неправдивої
інформації Росія виливає тоном
мільярдів доларів
українці не знайшли українців А і все для
фронту все для прямої витрати не культури
займався українською культурою
Ну, якщо мільйони на музей голодомору
велике харчування до водяниста дурих за
раз я розумію цькувати буду в цьому мости
було зроблено там ще не можна приїхати
через річку на мій міст але тут ірбінський
житоміром
єдине побудована з рукавички
бачили там через владу на Херсон
взування
на цих місцях і висловлює російську
модулю Ми навсе розуміло чудово
чомусь ясна таки майданчик як
фрідам
я і назвав якша я назвав синекуру і для
друзів
Нині я трактує
просто люди
поїхала що
їх фрази про те, що канал будинок рай роль
для Контр пропаганди для російської
мованих людей в основному українці не по
світла всередині Тому що повторю все
українські люди Кіровський він розуміють
українську на цих щоб говорити вдома
по дорозі ніколи не говоритиме
зрозуміло просто для своїх
людей і можна мені знайти
зради
інформативна політика
Ну я все те і ось мені удалося Що таке
кохану з пробував ніби міністр
культури хоч і до Ткаченка я скажу
чесно у мене мало претензій я Ну я чоловіку
такого ти міг бути написати там 20
пунктів але
розвивайся Ти прийшов
абсолютно
культурний такий
культурну дипломатію багата
культури
муніципалітетом культури
Булиба маса претензій чому не
вивезли з херсону там із Мелітополя до
знаючого росіяни там з кризою
кордону тут Нагано чому Вона не
висловилися ще там я йому ланцюг харчування
складні та ланцюг живлення
проводила кастинг Міністерство культури
Там вся пробували Я я працюю Вона
заклиналами так вудку типу не ходив би
ніби я сказала
Тобто
в результаті вони
Я просто розкладом
[музика]
Адже ти миєшся шириною драпалося і воно
кислота Хоча мені сказати ви могли дим і
як же тютюнові вся вири було І вам
тикала Будда зараз 6 хвилин
вже не ті кого Яни є чиновником
і маса людей не може
нічого посилювати та інтервал був
там цятки можете заробити хто
виявляючи все-всьому реальні руки і
механізми струмок
ось заголовного батчата Sense і мій
будні результату сейфи українські
заборони на законодавчо буде і
російський контент книга виставки вже мої
результати
Я сьогодні чесно вам зізнаюся їхала
таксист включав білоруську на російську
а білоруської як вона акція Макса Коржа
все-таки ведений
Ось чому
Зрозуміло
російський контент на добу тому що ви
думаєте
навушники вдома і слухатимуть російську
контент
Youtube включити концерт Юрій тут у
Лужники
[музика]
Олег якою сиру попливато ось зараз
оборону я знаю твій бізнес вступила вона
і Еме кассела всю заброню вимагала
Веста на початку двохтисячних руки Коли
росіяни океанулісу до Влади прийшли
фсбешники
особливо нинішнього президента і зросла
ще треба Україну повретатуріанський Союз
окупація Криму була собі як там через
місяць після
360 річковий
купайся нам здалося ще росіянам
приведуть за всім ще вони поважають своїм
Великому російському
актура він поважає своїм Він прийде його
викликає Я в чотирнадцятому Русі 14 руб
порада російська музика Ну я Я Ну так
там російські репертуар вийшло
редактура
Господи вибач Так ми йдемо
українські пісні 2016
[оплески]
худі з учасників у бравши пісню сива
ніч група Ласкаві майки дурні
публічно розум із продюсером захищала
особливо президента Путіна у меді про нами
їхні продюсери виступав з такою Позитив
чомусь іди така проскакувала
редактором
фільтрувала
зйомка опинившись
і через Всі ми не можемо сидіти дусі на
двох кріслах то ми вам скажемо
Сєрова там
скляра На тиждень до другого Так я вийду
у Комарова і такі пісні людей точно не
про путінському типу підкладками
російської
обумовлені І ще ми забронюємо чому
влада новий май но очевидному світі
редактор не знав, що директора депутатом
промови думаю час Вони будуть депутатом
продюсера до історії Ласкавий травень Думи та
голосували ми їх своїм депутатом
спочатку за приїдання Криму Ну будемо
обидва такі надавати
такі пісні
в ефірі була 52 добре
Я б сива ніч
стану на сьогодні було в російських Я
поїхав у сакраментом Російської пісні та
не тому, що він не просив, бо я
взяв Ми встигали за годину свинячим встигав
ще в одному місці там на зв'язку
російська пісня в репертуарі закон все
правильно я заспіваю що вони будуть допускати
і всі білі список несподіваний міністр
культури нікого не твердити білий список
артистки Типу ви не проїхати хороший
російська мова
матінку там е в Європі
[музика]
називається Росією і там критично або
праворуч шлях до нього Повстання людей і
так далі Ну можливо приїжджати
Що Ну все-таки заарештуєш та що
все-таки потрібно Ну люди потрібні люди
за допомогою стрибалкін тому що ви теж
Пугачової
виїхала демонстративно але мені дадуть
українську що хоче виступати і в нас
зим щоб були хоч страбоната більше
години російської культури просто вся
історія Я не знаю
повністю назад
і присягаюся при нас Миколі приїхав у
Україну
Давайте любити росіян тому що типу
ми не людожери, але гвинт за те, що твоя
держава не була в твоїх кордонах які
ти [ __ ] чиновник, а нинішня про
опонентійному та будні Влада Може людей
кемаль потенціал стати Владу в Україні
ми будемо моя теплоту силу з ясна повної
консиллінг абсолютно природним
ібіцами виступив у журнах росіян до тих
доки поки були винні Ібіца світить 200
Україна Еко запитує
блог би вони не буде такою ватою
директор клубу стереоплазу
Я не знаю
товариш типу
[музика]
Ну ще вона кома це суто українська
Зеленський став роздмухати трава вина
досьє відриваючи девакупатія наших
територій була духовна херсонщина до
ваш брат і Рубіна ви я Кострома це
зірку виїхав
заміжливості там мама З онуками
спочатку квідна руку братові іноді
вдалося виїхати тут у травник
територію Так І ось
якщо [ __ ] росіянами каховської АЕС
вони
постріляв вже в режимі онлайн
на українську землі
вдалося
вихідних територіях вже можна не лише
масштабного убік
територіях ніж ми жили екме туди ми
культурного рейтинг руваті з їхніх людей
люди шкіри Хто був викупації по ви не
Усе
дати
український володокповертається наступив
хоче жити в Росії чого Україні
вирішили напишуть що ми хочемо щоб тут
була присутність Росії
українська
допомагає фінансово там 50.000 100.000
доларів знайти
в Росії
все харчування би займалася тому що
Звичайно шиза абсолютно
психіатрична клінічна коли люди
просять прийти Путіна венесукраїну ми
говоримо про простих шизоїдів
еквівалась він і е його не можна раз все
більше зміцнилася Тому до харчування
культурно повернені з рукавичку я хотів
їх заплутані культурно повертати
Україну і проголосують
в українській
моя вибори буде
високу температуру
[музика]
ви думаєте що ціна є я думаю
що світ скаже так Україна дошити Ми ж
виграла на вас мільярди і давайте ми
будемо додавати
наші політики
ви вирішите що вже давності працювати
мобілізацію і так далі
вчинки але
нинішня влада
[оплески]
[музика]
Мася пішли
денний
річкові фази
Анни для ми не займатимемося серіали
займатимуться на російських
платформах
очевидно, що колаборацію нашої
кінематографісти щука з європейськими
партнером просто вказаним тому що
фільм росіянам ніхто
у Європі разом
достатньо для того щоб
на сьогодні ми не можемо вказати ще ми в
ППО культурному сансі в Європі
до Європи з
продукцією
своїх планів
[музика]
письмовий печасвини Державний фінансово
не така ж новизну платити, а по суті
створилася
створилася індустрія
ми не можемо як крилатої неділі що у
нас на моїй індустрії
маленький України в нашому розумі не
маленький територіально там Чехія
прибирання хто слова мені прийшло на те що
він їхня індустрія розвивається штрихом там
всі хребті
роз'ємів увагу майданчик
займає дещо хочеться
культури тому що він чудово
архітектура тобто
статистичність
блокбастери були успішними
стало супер успішно
та терпіння
була вдома була
[музика]
така теж
інтерв'ю хочу